what i want you to do is evaluate the
expression 5x squared
when
x is equal to 3. pause this video and
have a go at that
all right well we just have to think
about every place we see an x we'll now
replace it with a 3. so this is going to
be equivalent to 5 times instead of x
squared it's going to be 5 times
3
squared
and we know from order of operations we
do the exponents first that's why i
actually put a parenthesis around the 3
square to just make that clear and 3
squared is of course equal to 9 and 5
times 9 is equal to
45.
let's do another example that's a little
bit different let's say i have the
expression 1 3
times
6
to the x power and i want to evaluate it
when
x is equal to 2. pause the video again
and see if you can work that out
well once again everywhere where we see
an x we'll replace that with a 2. so
this is going to be the same thing as 1
3
times
6
squared where we saw the x we now
replace that with a 2.
and so this is going to be equal to we
do the exponent first order of
operations so it's going to be 1 3
times 6 squared is 36
and one third of 36 is equal to 12 and
we're done